nos piden que calculemos cuánto es un
séptimo dividido entre cuatro y nos
ayudan con este diagrama tenemos un
entero dividido en siete secciones
iguales cada una es un séptimo y tenemos
un séptimo coloreado
este es un séptimo y luego lo dividen en
cuatro secciones iguales
de hecho dividen todos los séptimos en
cuatro secciones iguales un séptimo que
es esta sección verde dividido entre
cuatro va a ser igual a esta fracción
del total que tiene un signo de
interrogación pausa en el vídeo y traten
de encontrar a qué fracción del entero
corresponde a este signo de
interrogación cuando dividimos el primer
séptimo en cuatro secciones iguales
también dividimos todos los demás
séptimos en cuatro secciones iguales y
ahora el entero está dividido en 28
secciones iguales porque tenemos una
cuadrícula de 4 por 7 tenemos 1 2 3 4
renglones y 7 columnas y las podemos
contar 7 14 21 28
así que un séptimo dividido entre 4 va a
ser igual a una de estas 28 secciones
esto que tenemos aquí es igual a 1 sobre
28 éste es un 28 a hbo hagamos otro
ejemplo
nos dicen que usemos la recta numérica
para ayudarnos a visualizar un quinto
dividido entre 3
como vamos de 0 a 1 en la recta numérica
podemos dividir en 5 secciones iguales
que serían un quinto dos quintos tres
quintos cuatro quintos y por supuesto
cinco quintos que es igual a uno pero
queremos un quinto dividido entre tres
así que tomamos la sección que va de
cero a un quinto y la dividimos en tres
secciones iguales y la primera de esas
secciones va a ser igual a un quinto
dividido entre tres así que a cuánto es
igual pausa en el vídeo nuevamente y
traten de resolverlo
la clave para resolverlo es que cuando
dividimos cada uno de los quintos en
tres secciones iguales podemos pensar en
cada una de estas secciones como un
quinceavo porque ahora tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 secciones
iguales entre 0 y 1 y de donde salió
este 15 bueno teníamos 5 secciones
iguales y dividimos cada una de estas
secciones en 3 secciones iguales
por 3 es igual a 15 de modo que este es
un quinceavo estos son 215 a vos
estos son 315 a vos que es equivalente a
un quinto y podemos continuar así pero
la clave para resolver esto es que si
tomo este primer quinto y lo divido en
tres secciones iguales y tomo esta
primera sección eso es igual a un
quinceavo un quinceavo terminamos